ok je vais présenter les césar mais
avant faut qu'on revoie les bases où je
vais faire une bande annonce sa housse
je vais dire des trucs sans parce que je
kiffe trop sont simples basiques hockey
les césar sont des trophées qui
récompensent le cinéma français
simple les nommer disent qu'ils s'en
foutent b s'ils l'ont pas ils sont
dégoûtés basique
oui on dit nommé tout le monde croit
qu'on dit nominés simple quand je pense
que l'année dernier j'étais sur mon
canapé basique une actrice liban tsl
n'est pas obligé de se dé saper simple
les producteurs de signer ne sont pas
tous des barrages d'agde est basique 120
battements par minute en vain la rouge
et le sens de l'appel simple la paix
tête de marc sur canal ouais en clair et
en direct basique
vous n'avez pas les bras vous n'avez pas
les basses vous n'avez pas les basses
tient là vincent elbaz basique simple
simple basique basique simple simple
basique les césars présentée par manu
payet vendredi 2 mars sur canal plus
simples basiques des exclusif